معنا من طهران مدير مكتب الجزيره عبد
القادر فايز ومن رام الله مدير مكتب
الجزيره وليد العمري عبد القادر اذا ذكرنا
سلسله اغتيالات عديده ولكن هذه ايضا
الاخيره التي قتل فيها اربعه مستشارين
احدهم ذو رتبه مهمه في استخبارات الحرس
الثوري الايراني لها وقع خاص ولكن ايضا
ايران تحاول ان تكون في موقف معين نريد ان
نفهمه
منك هذا صحيح حقيقه ايران تحاول ربما ان
تبقي نفسها في مساحه تسمح لها بان تفعل
شيء ما تجاه اسرائيل انطلاقا من ساحات
مختلفه وانطلاقا من ربما اعمال مختلفه
بعضها غير معلن يدور في مساحات الظل في
اعالي البحار او في مناطق اخرى مختلفه
ولكن دون ان يذهب ذلك بها الى تصعيد مباشر
ودخول حرب مباشره معلنه مع اسرائيل لماذا
لان التقدير الا استراتيجي هنا حقيقه في
طهران مياده يقول التالي بان اي معركه
مفتوحه الان مع اسرائيل ستجر بالضروره الى
معركه مباشره بين ايران والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وايران تفرق بشكل كبير
واستراتيجي حقيقه بين هذين المحددين
اسرائيل من جهه والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه من جهه هي تتعامل مع امريكا
والحضور الامريكي العسكري في المنطقه
بطريقه مختلفه كليا وبمنطق مختلف كليا في
تعاملها مع اسرائيل امنيا وعسكريا يبدو
بان المفضل لدى ايران هو ان تبقى هذه
المعركه في مساحات الرما الرماديه وفي
مساحات الظل وان تدور في هذه المنطقه ولكن
الواضح بان اسرائيل تضغط بقوه على عصب
الصبر الاستراتيجي الايراني لاخراج ايران
من هذه المساحات باتجاه مساحه معلنه
والدخول ربما اذا جاز التعبير الى حلبه
الملاكمه الاقليميه بشكل معلن امنيا
وعسكريا بين ايران واسرائيل ويبدو بان
ايران حتى الان تفضل البقاء تحت سقف
استراتيجي للموقف الرسمي للبلاد لا ذهاب
الى حرب معلنه ولكن لا بقاء ايضا مكتوب في
الايدي كيف ستوا ازن ايران بين هذا
الموضوع موازنه التهديد بالتهديد ولكن دون
الذهاب الى التصعيد هذه معادله صعبه حقيقه
مياده ولكن من يقرا يدرك كيف يتصرف الحرس
الثوري منذ اكثر من 20 عام في هذه المساحه
مساحات الاقليم وكذلك في اعالي البحار
يدرك بان لدى الحرس الثوري القدره ربما
على تصنيع ردود ما دون الاعلان عن ذلك
اليوم تتحدث ايران عن ضربه وازنه حقيقه في
سوريا ويبدو لنا من بعض المعطيات هنا ومن
بعض المصادر بان هناك اسماء مختلفه لذات
الشخص يوسف اميد زاده الحاج صادق حجه الله
اوميد فار يبدو بانها اسماء واحده لذات
الشخص وهو مسؤول ساحه سوريا في فيلق القدس
مسؤول استخبارات في فيلق القدس عن ساحه
سوريا ونائبه كذلك واسماء اخرى ضربه مواز
ربما وازنه موجعه مباشره لايران قبل ذلك
كان هناك اختيال ربما بهذا السقف الان
هناك من يقول مياده اورين ان اختم في هذه
النقطه وهي مهمه حقيقه هناك من يقول هنا
في ايران من العقول الامنيه الاستراتيجيه
عقول النخبه التحليل بانه ربما الدخول
خطوه واحده في الحرب المباشره بين ايران
واسرائيل بشكل معلن من قبل الحرس الثوري
هو الذي سيمنع وقوع هذه الحرب بمعنى
الذهاب الى الحرب ربما يمنع وقوع الحرب
بشكل منفلت ومفتوح بشكل كامل هل ستفعل
ايران ذلك لم يتم الحديث سيكون هناك تشييع
خلال اليومين القادمين سنسمع كلاما من
قيادات الحرس خلال هذا التشييع وربما تكون
الصوره اكثر وضوحا ماذا عن سقف اسرائيل
وليد العمري بالنظر الى هذه ضربات التي
كما وصفها عبد القادر هي موجعه
لايران هي موجعه ويعتبر ذلك انجازا وان
بقيت الروايه الرسميه غائبه في اسرائيل عن
هذا الموضوع لكن ما تتناقله وسائلها
الاعلاميه ويجود به ايضا المحللين في
اسرائيل كله يوحي بان من يقف وراء عمليه
الاغتيال هذه هي اسرائيل بحكم ان هذا
زمانا ومكانا وايضا الهدف كله خدم مصالحها
ثانيا اسرائيل ومنذ العام
2018 بدات ما اسمتها بالمعركه بين الحروب
ضد ايران وهي
تج تسير على عده مستويات منها السيبراني
منها استهداف العلماء اصحاب العلاقه
بالمشروع النووي الايراني ومنها ايضا
استهداف العسكريين او المسؤولين الكبار
خاصه من الحرس الثوري وتحديدا في منطقه
سوريا اسرائيل وتح تحت يافطه مكافحه
المشروع النووي الايراني ومحاوله احباطه
باشرت بهذه الحرب التي كان فيها الكثير من
الاغتيالات والان مع الحرب المتواصله على
غزه منذ لليوم ال 106 وايضا التوتر
المتصاعد على الجنوب اللبناني مع حزب الله
وفي بعض الاحيان التوتر على خط وقف اطلاق
النار مع سوريا اسرائيل تجدوا ان ذلك
مناسبا ايضا لمواصله عمليات الاغتيال ضد
الوجود العسكري الايراني في سوريا وفق
تعبيرها
وهذا الذي حصل اليوم عمليه الهجوم على
المبنى وقتل عدد مما كان فيه وتبين انهم
من المسؤولين الايرانيين الكبار هذا ياتي
ايضا امتدادا لقصف اسرائيلي كان قد استهدف
مواقع للجيش السوري على الجانب السوري من
خط وقف اطلاق النار الليله الماضيه بعد ان
ادعت اسرائيل بانها رصدت اطلاق قذائف من
هناك لذلك مثل هذا التوتر كان مستمرا في
المرات السابقه ويبدو انه سيتواصل في
الايام المقبله ايضا مديره مكتبي الجزيره
في رام الله وطهران وليد العمري وعبد
القادر فايز شكرا جزيلا لكما